bonjour mes amis si vous avez un chien
eh bien j'espère que vous êtes de bons
maîtres comme moi j'ai savais pas quoi
au boudin ficelle un adorable petit
chien comme à envoyer mon oncle
archibald
il s'appelle molosses et et nous allons
être très amis m'ont lancé mois regardez
comme il est mignon mais ça alors me los
balents souhait qu revient au quai me
lance ok ça lorsqu'il est passé mal en
ce moment sous et tu reviens on revient
vite 8000i tu n'as pas vu mon nom j'ai
pas vu me le fais mais qui est qui et
molosses
bon c'est vrai j'ai pas eu le temps de
t'expliquer voulons c'est un un adorable
petit chien commun comment renvoyer mon
oncle archibald
mais sur les paires du regard il ne
reste que le collier olala ainsi a perdu
sans collier
ça sera difficile à retrouver un bon je
vais voir françois françois provient que
tu n'as pas vu mon nouvel ami ton nouvel
ami qui s
mais ces melons son adorable petit chien
fou au moulin voulait que je mûris n'y a
pas de voleurs dans l'île aux enfants
qu'un petit que juillet moi nous allions
à ces recherches
oh mais julie elle perd toujours tout
alors non mais si monsieur merlan fumée
était là que commodités tu sèmes
merluche foncé mermet relance mais enfin
le plus grand détective du monde
ah oui j'y suis kazemi de veux parler de
monsieur merlotte paul ney c'est ça un
voyou je suis sûr qu'il le retrouve en
quasi mais ça tombe bien parce que tout
à l'heure j'ai justement rencontré sur
le port mais va vite le chercher
françois il ne faut pas perdre de temps
davantage signé d'accord d'accord j'y
cours
je suis certain qu'il va le retrouver
[Musique]
et
le
[Musique]
ok c'est bien le bonjour mademoiselle
gêné à bourg monsieur murdoch france
bonjour monsieur casino vous êtes enfin
là à monsieur merluche fumée mais là tu
fais mais oui mais l'homme dans ta comme
vous dites voilà je sais mais c'est
quasiment votre équipe
c'est ça c'est si vous le retrouvez vous
aurez une énorme récompense n'est pas la
taille pour la gloire de chez casimir et
la reine d'angleterre qu'elle est la
récompense vient cet homme un énorme
super gloubiboulga géant
je suis dit monsieur avoue trouver
vraiment cela délicieux de nous un joli
je suis un détective anglais pour que
pensez-vous de mon affaire et vie mais
je suis quasi miracle affaire très
compliquée ici pas facile tout oui et
bien mais c'est que gémir
si votre chien et 1 6 ess et il est
ailleurs
vous avez fait vous avez dû faire des
études énorme pour prouver ça tout seul
médine ou comment est touché à casimir
mais j'ai laissé jeu qui m'a excusez moi
monsieur once mais je croyais vous être
utile cela j'adore les témoignages
spontanés juillet vous appelez les
enfants s'il vous plaît tu es ma beauté
une cage de thé c'est vrai vous êtes
anglais les enfants venaient mais si
vous avez le droit de vous venez vite
les armes et demain vous asseoir jojo la
jeunesse asseyez-vous tout cela voilà
vous savez vous sur format c est
extraordinaire c'est le plus grand
détective du monde à l'au delà
le casino chien a disparu est-ce que les
deux vous le régime
non je te nuit selon lui personne ne l'a
vu non voilà votre thé monsieur merci
mademoiselle julie voudriez vous prendre
dans ma sacoche différentes gravure et
les moqueries aux offres
s'il vous plaît avec joie ma femme les
enfants
quel est le reste de ce chien c'est bien
payé votre chier était-il un lévrier
mais c'est que les unir non non non non
non le mien était plus haut
enfin moi mais je crois que je vois je
remets notre s'il vous plaît ne nous
elle se dit qu'elle est le reste de ce
chien c'est tout chaud et ecep jeu soul
non non non non pas du tout le monde
s'était passé chez nous et c'est
pourquoi elle s'est tous étaient en
baisse et à tes yeux
alors que j'ai mis mon nom était pas du
tout bas ça me artésiens n'ont a annoncé
jeudi le magazine ils n'ont rien à voir
c'est excellent en outre il est très
rigolo celui ci je trouve moi et y est
tu connais tous casimir monsieur et tout
ça nous menons s'il était bien plus bien
aura été différent quoi
[Musique]
tino jeu magnifique est celle où on
l'appelle comme encore le ciel
oui à berger allemand alors monsieur
casimir au nom alors vraiment pensé plus
compliqué est inquiète
d'incroyables faut sortir les gelées et
bien il n'y en a plus je tourne alors
vers le mystère s'épaissit
concentrez vous monsieur casimir
concentrez-vous il faut que je sorte de
cette impasse
votre chien le savait qu'il allait
signer particulier à non je ne vois pas
josé sur casimir
merci mon chien mois avec quelque chose
que tous ces chiens là non pas que j'ai
peut-être le but c'est ce que c'est eh
bien il avait quatre petites roulettes
sur les pattes
quatre petites roulettes que gémir tout
chien s'était jouée ce n'est pas à vous
et chine mardi c'était un chien jouait
quoi ouart a joué chien soutien je sais
où est ce que monkey moulant savoir je
sais que chaque académie
je les ai vus quittera dès ce matin dans
le jardin je les ramasse et je les mets
dans la malle magique merci je suis ça y
est votre chien petit je sais où il est
il est dans votre magic mail
alalala pourvu que la maille ne l'est
pas transformer en hérisson ou crapuleux
que j'allais devoir faire des farces et
je vais regarder si tu veux je te plaît
il est bien ici
casimir toucha s'est transformé en quoi
on a un vrai petit chien au caire comme
il est mignon
il est formidable oh mais c'est kevin et
vous êtes le peuple mais non ce n'est
pas à vous que je parlais monsieur wolf
s forme s tsé-tsé de mopti molosse aux
kills ou i oi oi